madame monsieur bonsoir un air de
nostalgie a flotté toute cette journée
en rade du havre avec l'arrivée pour une
escale de 10h de l'ancien pacte que vos
france rebaptisé norway le plus long
paquebot jamais construit 315 m arrivait
de new york avec à bord deux mille deux
cents passagers
c'est la première fois que ce paquebot
un revenez au havre son port d'attache
depuis sa vente en 79
pascal golomer et flippante wazi sont
montés à bord en compagnie d'un ancien
barman qui a refait la visite
et s'il a beaucoup changé de silhouette
n'ont à première vue comme ça a beaucoup
changé
tant pis pour les grincheux vivier varin
l'aiment bien ce nom
lui qui était descendue du france il y à
22 ans pour ne jamais y remonter
aujourd'hui la couleur est différente
deux ponts ont été rajoutés mais c'est
bien le même paquebot qui retrouve les
quais du havre
l'occasion est trop belle didier
l'ancien chef de rang l'ancien maître
d'hôtel du commandant s'embarque pour
une visite et il n'a pas besoin d'un
guide
le restaurant des premières classes
il n'a pas changé le décor est le même
seules les premières classes ont disparu
et leur faut travailler au milieu là on
disait on travaille sous les étoiles
la promenade elle a été couverte les
fauteuils ont remplacé les transats en a
pas changé
il y avait la salle de lecture et
d'écriture les livres de la bibliothèque
ne sont plus en français mais en anglais
et vira de bars etc
les virements le curve et un rapide coup
d'oeil sur l'une des suites avec balcon
désormais disponible c'est le luxe que
propose aujourd'hui le norway dernière
marche avant d'accéder au pont supérieur
ici aussi c'est nouveau pas de parquet
mais de la moquette
le bleu est de rigueur les cheminées ont
tout de même conservé leur silhouette
légendaire malgré les années malgré les
transformations et les coups de peinture
c'est bien le paquebot france son
paquebot que didier a retrouvé cet après
midi pour quelques petites heures